hello everyone and welcome to a most
amazing game that took place in 1950 in
the british championship it's a game
between uh
walter h and jonathan penrose and no it
is not
the the famous physicist that is sir
roger penrose but that is his brother
if you were wondering and it's uh it
comes as a suggestion from a subscriber
uh so thank you for that uh uh
uh suggested this and i've never seen
this one it's like
uh it's the shortest game that ever
happened uh in the official
british championship so uh it's uh
quite the game and uh it has has quite a
conclusion so uh without further ado uh
let's check it out so
uh and of course as usual as i do not
have a photo of mr vege
i'm uh honoring the hoodie guy by
wearing a hoodie myself and of course
i'm hoping you guys are as well
now um this is a photo of jonathan when
he was uh
14 but this game was played when he was
17 although i didn't find any photos
of him when he was 17. so in case you
were wondering
and i did actually find one photo of mr
vege but it's a photo from behind
and it's um from the chess history
website and
they're not even sure that it's him so i
decided to best the best keep it you
know
with the hoodie guy so without further
ado let's check it out as uh vich
opens with uh d4 uh penrose goes for
knight to f6 with c4
e6 uh knight f3 and d5 so nothing out of
the ordinary here
and i know you guys are wondering how
can this game last 10 moves this is the
position we see every day i mean pretty
much
in every game this is the queen's gambit
declined we have g3 preparing to
fianchetto the light square bishop
and here just d captures on c4 so this
is all very well known
uh knight b to d2 uh and now black
strikes in the center with c5 and here
with
white you should either continue
development with bishop to g2
uh or capture on c4 with the knight
however d
captures on c5 is uh quite an
imprecision to say the least
uh because here black recaptures bishop
captures in c5 and now white says
okay i mean my position is pretty good
i'm just going to play bishop g2 i'm
going to castle
and everything is fine but not so quick
because here bishop to g2 was played and
now
believe it or not the game is completely
lost and it's not all that easy to see
why so feel free to pause the video
and win this game for jonathan penrose
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
the queen is actually trapped and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
we start with bishop captures on f2 and
i know
most of you uh considered this move but
it's hard to see
where where it goes because after king
captures what was played in the game
of course king f1 is also playable but
then you just have a worse position
and you're going to suffer for the rest
of the game so you must accept the the
bishop sacrifice so king captures an f2
was played
now comes the knights the g4 again a
continuation most of you have checked
this comes with check and now of course
if king to f1
of course uh knight to e3 check and
white loses the queen but white says uh
i'm not going to play that i'm going to
play king to e1
and i still don't see the reason why you
sacrificed your bishop
but here comes knight the e3 and okay
the queen is under attack and it's
looking very scary but
the queen can go to a4 and this comes
with check so still
what was black's idea with the bishop
sacrifice well
queen to a for check this is the only
move and now comes the bishop to d7
and it was in this position on move 10
uh that
uh that uh walter vich resigned the game
as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
the point is
the queen is trapped all of the squares
are covered the queen covers a5 a6 is
covered by the pawn
uh there's nowhere for you to go you can
go to b4
or a3 but if you choose any of these
squares for example
queen to b4 knight to c to check wins
the queen and it's the same for queen to
a3
queen a3 knight to the c to check again
wins the queen this way
so this is uh one of the most unusual
ways i've ever seen
uh uh well for one player to blunder his
queen so bad
and for the game to be concluded so fast
in an official british championship
so this is pretty crazy and uh okay now
jonathan penrose is uh
is a university professor and he holds
the uh
he does have the title of grand master
but he officially has the title of
international master and he was a grand
master of correspondence chess but i
think in 1993
uh fide awarded him with the title of
honorary grand master
uh but he also has a phd and you know he
he he
uh does a lot of stuff but when he was
younger he was a fierce chess player as
you can see here he crushed uh
his opponent in 10 moves which is which
is incredibly impressive
and not only that he won the british
chess championship
10 times from 1958 to 1969 and as it
says
i will read you a very uh short segment
of an article from british chess
it says that uh penrose is one of the
outstanding figures of british chess yet
many who
meet him uh may not realize that just
because he's one of the quietest and
most modest of men
you may not realize this uh as he's uh
one of the uh
quietest and most modest of men
throughout the late 1950s and the whole
of the 1960s he stood
head and shoulders above any of his
contemporaries so
very nicely very nicely written and i
must admit i mean i've heard of him
before
but i don't think we've ever covered any
any of his games
and uh well uh you know we definitely
should
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and uh yeah
i i had no idea that he was in any way
related to sir roger penrose but
uh you know as it turns out yes he is he
is his brother
and it's a very nice game it would be a
shame not to know this game as it
i it could be even the shortest game in
any championship uh you know between
uh masters and grandmasters okay you
don't have to be like
in those days you didn't have to have a
title to participate but still it's the
official british championship i mean
this is uh
it's incredibly impressive that such a
game occurred so thank you for
suggesting
suggesting this to me and that also uh
shows that it's very important to use
hashtag suggestion when you uh
put suggestions in the comments section
so it's easier for me to
filter them out because i just go into
into my search bar i
write hashtag suggestion and then i get
all your guys uh
suggestions uh so yeah uh okay
enough said so that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like i would
like to thank
bonkcloud chess.com mabuta richardson
elegant missed triple triangle and
mustafa motivala for a contribution to
my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the morphe saga continuing uh
to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day